they were the husband and wife Jewel who
dominated the highest ranks of Scottish
politics for decades the pair who led to
the SMP machine the couple who will now
depart sooner than Peter Morrow would
have liked
he's obviously taken responsibility for
the recent issue with membership he had
intended to step down when there was a
new leader but I think he's right to
make that announcement today a far from
shock announcement from an embattled SMP
chief executive caught up in controversy
yesterday the party's Communications
boss resigned after being instructed by
the SMP to deny this newspaper report a
headline published weeks ago revealing
the huge drop in membership numbers
journalism the party's spin doctor was
told to describe as drivel unburdened to
him it was fact the true picture
concealed
quitting with immediate effect Peter
Morrell said while there was no intent
to mislead I accept this has been the
outcome the last attempt to do I was
assessor in the membership numbers was a
bit of known goal the membership number
should have been released frankly when
the contest started that's why I think
it's the right thing for Peter to have
done to stood down because as he said
his own words it was becoming a
distraction I really wanted to get on to
talking about you know the policies what
it is I'm going to bring forward finally
the next first minister of Scotland many
within the SMP have been saying for
years that it simply was not appropriate
for the chief executive of the party to
be married to the leader of the same
party and while this internal leadership
debate has brought about divisions The
crucial part is it's been brought into
the public Arena it's been bitter it's
been ugly and many suggested the longer
Peter Morrow remained in his position
the more damage he was doing to the SMP
and its credibility
this sorry Saga signals a reset for the
SMP it marks the end of the model
sturgeon era in a party left divided and
no closer to Independence as the
leadership battle rages on Conor Gillis
Sky News Glasgow